- I don't know how to run a business
that needs to perform
financially every 90 days
because I'm a marathon
runner, not a sprinter.
(shouting)
You got your perspective.
(cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(jazzy piano music)
- Hello everyone, I'm Andy Serwer.
Welcome to Influencers,
and welcome to our guest, Gary Vaynerchuk,
Gary, great to see you.
- Great to see you.
- Although, I should say our host,
because we're here,
at your building in Long Island City,
so thank you for having us here.
- We're thrilled to have you.
- So let me ask you this
very basic question.
- Sure.
- How would you describe yourself?
Say, my six-year old nephew.
What do you do?
- I'm an entrepreneur,
at its most purest sense.
I am an operating-entrepreneur,
who happens to put out a
lot of personal content
of that journey,
so, there is some awareness
of who I am as a human,
but at the end of the day,
I'm an executive of
several companies that I run,
VaynerMedia and the
VaynerX holding company
of agencies and
service-providing companies
is really, really, really what I do.
And that's it.
It's not super-complicated
other than the fact, that I decided
that it was in our business interest
and in my own curiosity
of what would it be like
if you documented and produced content
at a scale that had never been seen before
around an executive.
What would it have looked
like, if Ariana Huffington
when she started the Huffington Post,
what if she put out five to
10 pieces of content a day,
in podcasts, vlog, and content
across all those social platforms,
every day of the first
six years of that journey?
What would that look like,
and that's what I decided to do.
- I mean, in a way, it's kind of timeless,
like the entrepreneur part,
on the other hand, you
couldn't do what you do today,
say, 20 years ago.
- Not only that, I didn't
do, what I do today,
when I ran my first company.
- When I took the reins of my
dad's liquor store in 1998.
The cynical part of being so out-and-about
is the showmanship, the
narcissism, the self-promotion.
I try to remind people, I'm like, "Look...
A lot of times the accolades
that I get in business today
people pass-off as,
"Well he's internet-famous and
that's why it's happening."
So, it undermines my
operational and executive skills
and when I get sad about that in a debate
or a conversation with a friend or a foe,
I try to remind them like,
"Look, I was a 22-year old kid,
"who from 22
"to 28,
"grew a business from 3 million
to 60 million dollars a year
"and I didn't make content.
"I wasn't on the internet.
"I was an operator.
"I was a marketer."
And so, yes, you're absolutely right.
Not only could other people
have not done it in the past,
I already lived an entire chapter
of building an entire business
that had nothing to do
with having a personality
attached to it.
I was just the operator of.
- Yeah, it's pre-internet.
And yeah, you needed your social skills,
but you were running an
operating-business as you said.
But let me ask you,
you've got 5.5 million
followers on Instagram,
1.8 million on Twitter.
How do you do that?
I mean, I always hear people,
"Oh, you just create
content and you sit there."
But it couldn't possibly be that easy.
- Well, it's definitely not that easy.
That would be like saying,
"How do you become a
professional basketball player?"
You just play basketball.
Like how do you become...
- Do you need talent then?
- Yes.
- So what's the talent?
- By the way,
let's stay here for four seconds,
because this is a huge platform,
and I think we're about
to help a lot of people.
The number one non-conversation
going on in today's society
around influencers and other things
is the talent part.
- Mm-hmm, right.
- Now, talent comes in
all shapes and sizes.
Your talent may be that you're a model.
You're just very attractive.
- That's me.
- Right?
- You know that.
- No, that's not me.
- Right?
- Yes.
Or a comedian or an athlete,
or a thought-leader.
I do believe that
education and entertainment
are the two pillars,
but yes,
back in 2006,
I started making wine videos on YouTube.
In 2007, I aggressively
put out content on Twitter.
Had the things coming out of my mouth,
not been interesting to people,
I would not be sitting
here with you right now.
It's not super-complicated.
Most people have taken
some version of an attempt
to become, somebody, people
know on the internet.
Most people.
You know there's a set
that's very private,
most people have taken a dabble
into a LinkedIn article,
into a nice photograph
they posted on Instagram,
into a single YouTube video,
a couple clever tweets,
most people have tried.
- Right.
So what's the secret
of making people engage with your content?
I mean it's just smarts?
- Empathy.
- [Andy] Empathy, okay.
- Empathy's the secret.
I believe, I sit
at where I am in the Lexicon,
which is, I think,
a winning player in
today's new environment
because I'm empathetic to my audience.
I put out content, that brings them value,
not, makes me feel good about myself.
- Right.
How many posts do you put up
a day in Insta and Twitter?
And those are your two main platforms?
- Those are the two main platforms
that I myself completely control.
LinkedIn, Facebook, YouTube,
I've over the last three or four years
amassed a team of content-creators,
media-amplifiers, strategists
around my content,
but I fully control Instagram and Twitter
and I put out four Instagram,
regular posts
(train horn sounding)
and probably,
anywhere between three
and 25 tweets a day.
- So, that's a lot.
- By the way, big shout
out to you and your team,
because the train going by now,
the fact that you guys didn't stop it.
I am so pumped right now.
I'm fired up.
- We wouldn't stop for that.
If my phone rang we wouldn't stop.
- I love that.
- That's like old people,
old school stuff.
- But there is an evolution
in content creation.
Like it literally just took note
I'm like, "Oh, I like these...
good job.
- Good.
- Go.
- And that's empathetic.
So, how does the business model work?
So, explain your company to me.
Is it VaynerMedia,
is that the entire business--
- VaynerMedia was the first company
for about six or seven years--
- You know, but look
this is Vayner water--
- Yeah, I mean that's
just inside stuff, yeah, yeah.
That's an inside stuff for us.
We have fun with that
but VaynerMedia was the first company,
after building up Wine Library
and then, after being an investor
in Facebook, Twitter, Tumblr,
and having kind of Silicon Valley success,
I decided to start the
agency with the premise that,
eventually, I would wanna buy
nostalgic and historic brands.
And I would run them through my
progressive, consumer-centric
marketing model.
So, I started an agency.
It grew very quickly,
now there's something called VaynerX
because two years ago
I bought PureWow.com,
a women's lifestyle brand,
we started a men's brand
recently, called ONE37pm.
Then we started a speaking
bureau six months ago
called VaynerSpeakers.
We started a company in January
to service small businesses
'cause VaynerMedia's
made for Fortune 500s,
called the Sasha Group, named
after my dad, which is fun.
We have a tech platform called Tracer
that is evolving in a separate company,
so, now there's a VaynerX holding company,
and very honestly,
it's really no different than
Publicis or Omnicon or WPP,
or, for people who are watching,
it's just Mad Men, 20/20, right?
Obviously, a hell of a lot.
I haven't watched the show
but I assume, what
they've had on the show,
it's a heck of a lot culturally better.
- Right, right, right, right.
- It's an advertising agency.
- Right, so the business model works
like, you have Fortune 500 clients,
like, give me some names.
- Chase, Budweiser, Pepsi, Hulu.
- And they pay you money--
- Service fees.
- To make campaigns?
- Make pictures,
and videos on the internet
and on television.
Planters' Super Bowl spot this year
was made by this production
company that we're in
and ideated creatively by VaynerMedia.
We are paid to make pictures,
videos, written words,
marketing collateral.
What's unique about VaynerMedia,
in today's world is,
under the same roof, we also
then are the media agency
that places the media.
We buy the ads on Facebook,
Twitter, YouTube, Yahoo,
we do the execution.
That was the way it was
done in the 60s and 70s.
The same people that made it,
also bought the television.
Then they separated them
and now most agencies
either do creative or media.
VaynerMedia does both.
- I mean a lot of people
say that ad-businesses,
the legacy companies,
I mean certainly they're
under a lot of pressure,
Is this sort of a new model,
a good way to do things?
- I think so.
Yeah, I agree
with the street and the
business pontificators
that the old model's in trouble
but I don't think it's necessarily
because they didn't have media
and creative under one roof.
I believe it's because they
were publicly-traded companies,
and they had to make their own numbers,
and when you're a service provider,
if you only care about your
EBDA and your stock price,
your clients, eventually
are gonna feel that.
And when they feel that
and they feel the negative effects...
I actually believe there's an
incredible book to be written
similar to "Barbarians at the Gate",
of what the four or five
biggest holding companies
in the world have accomplished
in the last 25 years,
which is through consolidation,
they have basically extracted the value
out of the biggest brands in the world.
If you look at the biggest
brands in the world
that have used the
publicly-traded agency model
over the last 20 years,
they've declined,
while the agencies have grown.
Only now, are they starting to decline
because the cat's out of the bag
'cause the biggest brands in the world
are starting to look at Vayner
and other independent alternatives
and that's bad for the holding companies.
- So, you wouldn't
necessarily look to go public?
- I'm incapable of being a CEO
of a publicly-traded company.
So, no, we will not.
- Yeah, maybe Elon Musk
should have said something
like that at one point.
- I don't know Elon well enough
and I know he's a character.
I'm not incapable because
I wanna curse on video.
I'm incapable because I don't
know how to run a business
that needs to perform
financially, every 90 days
because I'm a marathon
runner, not a sprinter.
- That's kind of refreshing to hear that,
you don't necessarily need this payout.
But you don't need that
for your employees,
I mean, there are a lot
of private companies
that have been around for
decades and decades, right?
- That's exactly right.
- You don't have to go public, right?
- No, I don't want the cash
infusion to buy a boat.
I want to enjoy running a company
and I need independence
as an entrepreneur.
And so,
I'm not willing to give up my independence
for 400 million dollars up front.
- So, you were running a liquor store--
- Yes.
- And then, the internet happens.
How and when did you realize
that the internet was gonna revolutionize,
let's just say, the business of
communication--
- October 1994.
- You have a date?
- I do, I'll tell you why.
October of 1994 was
the October of my
freshman year of college.
And...
In 1991, when I was in high school,
that's when I started becoming passionate
about my dad's liquor store,
and I said, "I'm gonna open 150 of these.
"I'm gonna open the Toys
"R" Us of liquor stores."
I remember being a high
school kid thinking.
And then, in October of 1994,
I went into my friend's dorm room
and discovered the internet.
And within 10 minutes,
I found myself on a baseball
card bulletin-board on AOL,
and I saw that people were selling.
And actually,
- There we go.
- They're not gonna see it,
but you're gonna see it.
- Where?
- These are literally--
goosebumps--
- Goosebumps,
that's goosebumps.
- That's right.
This is real goosebumps,
and I'll tell you why,
it changed my life.
I mean I'm really getting them right now.
- That's legit.
- So, I'm excited about this
'cause it was a really
transcending moment.
I'm a weird kid,
meaning I was a true entrepreneur.
- '94 was early but that
was before Netscape.
Way before Netscape.
- I'm not sure the timing--
- Yeah, yeah, but it was.
- Is that right?
I believe you.
- 'Cause you were on
an AOL bulletin board.
- Yep, yep.
And I just remember thinking
this is it.
I don't know what else to say.
I was like this is it,
and literally two years later,
'cause it took a little bit of time,
I launched winelibrary.com,
one of the first e-commerce
wine businesses in America
and it changed the course of
my family's wine business.
- So how do you build an online brand?
- Easily.
You produce content
on the seven to 25 places
where people pay attention,
and you produce it around things you know,
and you amass awareness.
How did Nike build a brand?
They ran commercials.
They did sponsorship.
It's just attention arbitrage.
- What does that mean?
- For me it means,
my career,
oftentimes, I reference Mariano Rivera,
when I talk about my career.
- Mo.
Mo was one of the great
closers in baseball history.
- Robbie knows that.
He's a big Yankee fan.
- And so, you're gonna appreciate this.
He had one pitch.
He was solid at everything else,
but he had this one pitch.
And besides Edgar Martinez,
literally, nobody could hit it.
And that's who I think I am.
I'm good at other things,
I'm good COO, I can operate,
that's why I have businesses.
I'm very good at HR.
I'm good at PR.
I'm good at other things.
This is me now talking about myself.
If you ask me,
I think, I'm remarkable at understanding
what humans are actually doing
before the masses
understand they're doing it.
Right?
I understood that online dating, in 2001,
was gonna be mainstream.
That wasn't obvious until 2011, right?
Or '13 or, whenever Tinder
really took hold, right?
And so,
what I mean by that is,
I built Wine Library on the back of e-mail
and Google AdWords.
In 1997,
no liquor-store in America,
thought it was a good idea
to build up an email-newsletter,
versus, the catalog that
they could send in the mail.
Got it?
- Right, yeah.
- In 2001, I bought every Google AdWord
for every wine term
and nobody was bidding me up.
- Right, got it.
- Got it?
- Yep.
- In 2006, this is now
documented, thank God.
In 2006, I started a wine show on YouTube
in February, 2006.
I was one of the first people
to move fast on Twitter.
I have podcasts, and...
I'm consistently first
and that skill has allowed
me to be good at real-estate.
- Right.
- Somebody bought up all of Dumbo.
Somebody once bought up most of Malibu.
Some people see it.
I see human behavior.
- Okay, so, what do you see right now?
- Voice.
- What does that mean?
- That means that everybody in this room
and everybody who's watching this video
is gonna do a lot more things
with Alexa and Google Home and Apple Pod
than they think today.
- Like what?
- Order every single food that they eat.
All of it.
In 13 years, you will mouth,
in your office, in your home,
you will say, "Send me a burger."
Or, "Can you get me a Shake Shack?"
Or, "I wanna a Whatchamacallit bar.
"Get me my Sprite."
- Quinoa.
- That's right.
- Even--
- I want a quinoa salad.
And this is where branding comes in.
I want a quinoa salad.
If you say that to Alexa,
Amazon, now has a lot of leverage.
What quinoa salad are they gonna send you?
Their own private label?
Is some brand gonna pay
$500 to be the affiliate?
So you better say, "I want
Sweet Greens quinoa salad."
Which is why brand
is about to become so much more...
Brand has always been the most important.
Brand's about to become
even more important
because we're going to an
audio-centric legion world,
not a visual-centric.
It's gonna be very big.
- It sounds like you think
Amazon has a lot of upside here.
- I sure do.
- Yeah.
- Unless the government gets involved,
which, I don't know that stuff.
That's above my pay grade.
I would buy Amazon stock in perpetuity
until Jeff Bezos no
longer runs the company.
- But, Amazon, Google, Facebook, Twitter,
they have a lot of advertising power.
Does that concern you,
that they've got so much of that pie?
- Of course not,
'cause CBS, ABC and
NBC had that whole pie.
Because the New York Times
and the Washington Post
had all that pie.
Yahoo at one point.
There's always somebody
that controls the pie.
- And always people whining about it.
- That's right.
Microsoft should have been broken up.
IBM should have been broken up.
Google should be broken, now...
it's the same old game.
- Should they be broken up, Facebook?
- I don't think so.
Mainly, because I think that there's
always another Young Turk,
coming up and she or he is
gonna destroy Mark Zuckerberg
because Mark Zuckerberg becomes passive.
Because Jeff Bezos becomes passive.
'Cause Bill Gates becomes passive.
Because people become passive.
- Right.
They become content,
they become--
- Content, old, curious in other things,
different parts of their life.
Sick, die.
This is run by people.
- Yeah, yeah.
So we're in Long Island City,
we just talked about Amazon.
- Yes.
- What did you think about that?
Was the city right to boot them out,
or activists right to boot them out?
- I am so pumped you asked this question.
- [Andy] Good, let's talk about it.
I have no idea.
- (laughing) Come on, man.
You said you wanted to talk
about that and you're punting.
- I'm not punting.
- Okay.
- The reason, I just got so excited, is,
as a guy who speaks with heavy conviction,
which could come across as audacity
or ego or overconfidence,
nothing excites me more,
than when I'm interviewed,
when I actually don't know
the answer to something
and I can say, "I don't know."
- But that's just it,
so why don't you know?
That's the follow up question.
- Because I'm not willing
to do the homework of
the collateral things
that happen after the fact, right?
I don't understand, the actual math around
my intuitive nature is,
when the greatest company in the world
or definitely in America,
wants to set up shop,
that, that has, trickle-down value prop.
What I don't know,
is the concessions that
the state or the city does,
and the arguments on both
sides of the equation
properly and possibly have
actual value to them,
I just haven't taken
the time to dissect it.
Let me give you an example.
I believe that TV advertising
is grossly over-priced.
- Right.
- I also think that the Super Bowl
is the number one best buy in marketing.
So that's a contradiction
within the micro of the macro.
That's why I can't answer to LIC.
I don't know.
- Right, right.
What do you think about
politicians like Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
who says that we should have
more government involved
in terms of people making higher wages?
- You know, it's an interesting question.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
So I laugh when Americans try to paint
liberals as socialists or communists,
'cause that's Americans that
haven't lived in communism.
- [Andy] Right.
- So here's what I would say,
I am stunningly socially liberal.
At the same token,
I'm an alpha-entrepreneur
and believe in many of
the things of capitalism.
What I don't like is
when capitalism gets old
aka an Alpha gets old,
and then she or he
tries to use their money
to change the rules of merit.
So, I'm disgusted by that.
At the same token,
I have many 20-year-old kids
hitting me up and saying,
"Gary, you're rich, you
should give me your money."
So, I'm very scared of this slippery slope
of massive entitlement.
- Yeah.
- So,
more government involvement
doesn't hit me well in my
alpha, player-on-the-field,
I'm an entrepreneur.
It hits me tremendously well as,
I'm the human being
and I want everybody
to be healthy and happy
to the best of our abilities.
I think the answer is
always somewhere in between.
The biggest problem I have...
listen, I'm willing to
give up 95% of my earning.
I really am.
Let's go to taxes.
- Maybe getting close
to that in this state.
- I'm willing to.
I just wanna be the one who gives it away.
- Mm-hmm, right.
- Wait a minute,
I'm gonna work my face off,
bleed in perpetuity,
and I'm gonna give it to you,
and you're gonna decide,
who got 36,000 votes?
And you've never operated
anything in your life?
And you're third-generation wealthy
or your ideology,
and you have no practical skills?
This is not about giving away money,
it's about giving away
money to people that
have no idea what to do with it.
That starts where, it
gets a little complicated.
So, I want everybody to be
awesome and happy and healthy,
and I'm willing to pay
unbelievable amounts for it,
I just wanna see how
you're gonna spend it.
- Right, right, right.
Shifting gears a little bit--
- Please.
- Everyone wants to be an entrepreneur.
Well maybe not everybody
but a lot of people do
but very few people
actually pull the trigger
and even fewer succeed.
What are the barriers there?
- Talent.
- That's disheartening.
That means you're just...
you can either play in
the NBA or you can't.
- No, that's a very good point.
I think it's the following.
My brother AJ is a better
basketball player than me
'cause he's put in more work
on his left hand and his jumper,
so, he deserves it.
He's not in the NBA.
You can be an entrepreneur,
the problem is,
we've lost sight of, being an entrepreneur
who makes $137,000 a year,
doing what she or he loves,
is an amazing life.
But right now, everybody thinks
they're gonna be Mark Zuckerberg.
So we've become audacious and ludicrous
and delusional in our
entrepreneurial ambitions.
And so, I think we need a
level of self-awareness.
I think people are trying
to be entrepreneurs
at a level we've never seen before
'cause the cost of entry
of saying that you're an entrepreneur
in your Instagram account is very easy.
- Right.
- It's also cool right now.
I'm actually quite scared about that,
because I don't wanna be the face of that
because I think 95% of
people are gonna fail.
Especially when the economy fails.
Let me say something straight to camera.
If you're not a successful
entrepreneur right now,
in the easiest time to be
a successful entrepreneur
'cause there's so much money in the system
and the internet is that scale,
you suck.
- All right.
That's some tough love right there.
- It's the truth.
This is the easiest time,
in the history of life,
to be a successful entrepreneur
and if you're not and you're struggling,
then, you're not an entrepreneur.
Listen, I'd love to be playing
for the Jets and the Nicks
or be opening the Grammys.
It's fun, it sounds rad.
I'm just not capable.
It doesn't mean I can't sing better.
It doesn't mean I can't be
a better football player,
backyard, in Central Park.
You gotta put in the work,
and you have to be
self-aware of your upside.
The other thing is,
we have too many students
who now think that
entrepreneurship is cool.
If you weren't selling
lemonade and baseball-cards
or pogs or burning CDs and
flipping them in school,
if you don't have sales-DNA
or operational-DNA,
or it wasn't fun to play
Store when you were five,
you didn't gravitate towards it naturally,
you're gravitating towards
it now 'cause it's cool.
- Right.
And I take it you did all those things.
- All those things.
And so did, so many,
of the people that are successful
as entrepreneurs.
The same as singers went to choir,
the same as actors signed
up for this Thespian Club
at freshman year.
Like it matters.
The work matters, the talent matters.
- What about--
You don't get to wake up one day
and just say, "I'm going to
start the Uber of bananas."
It's just crazy what's going on out there.
Just, the greatest generation of
fake-entrepreneurship we've ever seen.
- Yeah, that's 'cause of the Internet...
- 'Cause it's cool.
- It's cultural.
- If us said, "We're gonna be rappers",
that's cool too but very quickly
we have to prove if we can rap.
I'd be like, "Cool, rap!".
And then, you can't and you're like,
"You're not a rapper".
I could say, "I'm gonna
be a basketball player".
I'm like, "Cool, show me!".
You can't prove to somebody
in one second that you're
not an entrepreneur.
- Right, right.
So, let me ask you about speaking.
- Okay.
- You do speaking right?
- I do.
- Motivational-speaking you could call it.
Are you concerned, Garry,
that it's manipulative?
- Of course.
- But I don't think I'm manipulative.
I think that people wanna
make me a motivational-speaker
but I'm not.
If you go watch one hour
of Keynote on YouTube,
listen to what I'm saying.
I'm not talking about The Secret,
just listen to the words.
I'm motivational in my DNA.
I'm a rah-rah guy.
I'd be a great high-school couch.
I know, how I come-off
but I ask anybody who wants
to throw that cynicism at me
to go read the transcript
of what I'm saying.
I am the most practical,
emigrant, operating person
you will find.
There is no delusion in my optimism.
- [Andy] Right.
- There is no delusion in my optimism.
It's funny that you ask me that question,
based on the last six
minutes of this interview
if you think about it, right?
It makes me happy the way it went.
I don't think the last
six minutes were like,
"Hey, and I'm gonna manipulate
it, that it's so easy".
I'm desperately, trying to
tell people this is super hard.
I'm equally saying, "How lucky
are we that we can even try?"
Our grandparents couldn't start a company
after-hours on a phone.
This is the greatest era of the at-bat.
You're not guaranteed to hit a home-run.
- Right, right.
- This is greatest era of the at-bat.
That's cool.
That makes happy, there's
a lot of people struggling,
paying for college loans and
they get home at 7:00 p.m.
and I'm saying to them,
"Let me motivate you to not use Netflix
"and 2K and beer to escape your problems.
"Let me motivate you at 7 p.m.
to spend the next five hours
to build something for
yourself on Shopify or Ebay
or Instagram or YouTube to get
you out of your situation."
Got it?
- Yeah, I got it.
- It's practical.
I actually believe that my
natural showmanship-DNA,
my shtick that is my DNA, grossly
undermines what I'm doing.
People think it's why I'm successful.
I think it's undermining my upside.
- 'Cause, people just say
you're all form and no content.
- I literally threw up in
my own mouth when you said
I was a motivational speaker.
- Okay, I'm sorry.
I didn't want to do that to you.
- You didn't but I'm telling
you a very important truth.
- Yeah, okay.
- I get it and I understand
that I look that part
but I continue to push people
to listen to what I'm saying.
I'd love to be lower but I'm pump.
- That's who you are.
So, how do you prioritize?
How do you allocate your time?
Number one.
- My admins rule my life.
I literally, had no clue we
were doing this just now.
- We're doing it.
- I'm aware
She walked over, she's like,
"You ready?", I'm like, "okay."
I didn't even know it was the Yahoo! one.
My calendar rules my life.
Me and my team are thoughtful
about what we book.
I spend the far majority
being the operator of Vayner
but I do use my personal brand as a
top-of-the-funnel awareness
to drive my business.
- [Andy] Right.
- Right? So, bring value...
I'm filming this for my own content,
bringing in value for to
your platform and then
the serendipity of somebody
becoming aware of me,
digging-in then looking.
So, I do use my personal
brand, as a top-of-the-funnel,
business-development-tool
for my businesses.
- Where do you wanna take this?
It's the old, "Where do
you want to see yourself
"20 years from now Gary?".
But, I mean, it's important.
- No, no, it's very important.
I like being thoughtful of
what I'm doing professionally.
The two things that I'm most excited about
are the continuous
journey, of the ambition,
of trying to buy the New York Jets.
Which is my absolute professional goal.
- Really?
- That's right.
- Are you serious about that?
- As a heart-attack.
Yeah, it's been my goal for my whole life.
- [Andy] Do the current owners know this?
Are they aware of this?
- You know, it's funny,
I'm not sure and I have no
interest in wasting their time
because I'm not, anywhere close yet,
to the financial level that I need to be.
Probably do.
I put it out there quite a bit
and my path to that is
to build Vayner Media,
to build the greatest
marketing engine in the world,
to then buy historic brands,
when the economy collapses.
So, I wanna buy Tootsie Rolls or
Reebok or...
- [Andy] Right.
- And then I wanna become the CEO of that.
So, I wanna buy something
in the next decade
for 2 hundred-million
to 5 hundred-million,
then, I want to run it for a decade
and then flip it, for
3 billion to 5 billion
and buy the Jets
and then, I wanna make content
that leaves a positive legacy
in allowing people to, at least,
use me as a context point.
This is how I'm doing it.
Take what works for you
and place some legacy on the content.
- Wow, that is well thought-out
and clearly defined.
- I appreciate it.
- How do you see yourself,
using your influence on the world?
It's kind of at your core.
- I believe that in 40
years, people will realize,
during this period of time,
that, I was one of the
few unique individuals,
who had the ability penetrate
15 to 25 year old, young men
and was able to re-frame their mind
of not being as, into
watches and private jets
and models and cash
but made them start respecting things
like patience and gratitude
and empathy and kindness
and that I will be far-more
revered, after I'm gone,
for doing it, then I'll ever be
while I'm around doing it.
- Garry Vaynerchuck, thanks so much
for talking with us today and
thanks for having us here.
- Thank you.
- I'm Andy Serwer, you've
been watching Influencers.
We'll see you next time.
Great, that was super-cool, I loved it.
- [Gary] Thank you, thank you.
- Really, really, interesting.
- [Andy] I loved it.